so I want you to know that I did try to
avoid doing this daily cancellation I
tried my best to resist the lwh hanging
fruit I mean there are so many other
worthy canceles so many others who are
just just as deserving of the honor so
why subject all of us to this why Force
the audience to listen to the thing that
I'm about to force you to listen to must
we do this must we spend our time on
this well yes we must uh I'm sorry but
we must the rapper Ice spice has a new
song out titled thank you the fart and
the fart is in parenthesis by the way
this is a parenthetical fart uh it's
important that I mention that so that
you can fully appreciate all of the
artistic subtleties of this song and um
well that is the only artistic subtlety
to be clear but still kind of impressive
for a musical artist who I'm willing to
bet $10,000 cannot spell the word
subtleties in the first place but in any
case this new uh ice spice song came out
just a few days ago it's already a hit
music video has nearly 9 million views
on YouTube it's Been streamed over 15
million times on Spotify which is the
real test of a song's popularity these
days overall ice spice who emerged on
the music scene just two years ago or so
has garnered hundreds of millions of
streams hundreds of millions more views
on YouTube She's achieved widespread
popularity especially on Tik Tok she's
been featured in songs with Taylor Swift
she's been on the Barbie movie
soundtrack so she is by every
quantifiable measure a Bonafide musical
Superstar but is she any good well you
might assume from the tile of her latest
song that the answer to that question is
no you might want to dismiss her talents
altogether without even giving her a
chance based on what you know about
rappers these days and about the music
industry and about the sorts of musical
artists who put words like and fart in
the titles of their songs let alone both
words in one title you might arrogantly
and presumptuously disregard her from
the outset and I want you to know that
if that's your attitude then it is
absolutely correct uh her music is
indeed indeed as hideous and
mind-numbing as you imagine this 45
second clip of her performing her latest
track at the Spotify Best New Artist
event should be enough to prove the
point here it
is what
even I be
going I'm breing
Hearts be Qui but I'm
quier but I'm thicker she could be rich
but I'm richer
D Man
man don't give a don't give a in the and
keep keep I'll make me
[Music]
some you know we've talked uh before
about the incredible prophetic accuracy
of the movie Idiocracy which came out in
2006 it imagines a dystopian future
where average IQ scores have plummeted
well below room temperature and American
culture has become so crash and stupid
that for example the biggest hit reality
show in in this this universe is called
Owl my balls and it features a guy
getting hit in the balls by various
objects the only thing that idiocracy
got wrong is that it predicted things
would get that dumb in 500 years but
instead it took less than 20 in fact a
song called than you the fart sounds
like it's taken directly out of the
idiocracy screenplay we have reached our
futuristic idiot dystopia and we didn't
even need a time machine to get there it
goes without saying that the lyrics of
this new ice spice song are so Juvenile
and witless that simply listening to
them causes brain damage uh popular
music has gotten so dumb that exposure
to it causes actual concussion symptoms
we all now probably have CTE just from
watching that clip and I don't mean to
belabor the point but just to make it
clear here are some of the lyrics of
this song in case you couldn't
understand what she was babbling
about I said 400 bands I said 400 bands
just to do my little Dance I'm A brand
I'm a baddie I get what I want all in
balenci I look like a bum I got the
jaddy is that jaty is that missell jaty
he just want a hump walk through and
start shaking my hips I'mma dip when I
stack all my chips strip a dummy I want
the whole
fit I got a French nword sending me tips
thank you the you're not even the fart
I'd be going hard I'm breaking their
hearts be quick but I'm quicker be thick
but I'm thicker she should be rich but
I'm
richer
now sure based on these lyrics you would
assume that English is her second
language and she doesn't have a first
language uh ice spice has the the
intelligence and artistic sensibility of
an earthworm this song is the musical
equivalent of an overflowing portapotty
that's been baking in the Sun for three
weeks the uh think you that you're not
even the fart is it's the sort of
metaphorical play on words that wouldn't
even count as clever if this woman was
in thir grade like even an 8-year-old
would hear that and think that it lacks
sophistication the whole thing is so
vapid and stupid and meaningless that
you can't listen to it for very long
before plunging into despair I mean
listening to this kind of music is like
staring into the abyss it's like some
kind of great void where Beauty and
meaning and intelligence are consumed
and obliterated Grand Canyon University
is a private Christian University in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona GCU believes
that our creator has endowed us with
certain unalienable rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
they believe in equal opportunities and
that the American dream starts with
purpose GCU equips you to serve others
in ways that promote your flourishing
which will create a ripple effect of
transformation for generations to come
whether you're pursuing a bachelor's
Masters or doctoral degree gr can
University's online on campus and hybrid
learning environments are designed to
help you achieve your degree GCU is over
330 academic programs as of September
2023 GCU will meet you where you are and
Prov provide a path to help you fulfill
your unique academic personal and
professional goals find your purpose
today at Grand Canyon University private
Christian affordable visit gcu.edu
that's gcu.edu in a just world you would
go to prison for making music this bad I
don't even mean because it's profane or
whatever I just the music itself is so
bad you should go to jail for it there
there should be jail sentences for this
so in that sense it's really no
different from most pop music these days
and indeed it's it's essentially on that
basis that many people Miss concerns
about the absolutely god- awful Soul
crushing ugliness and idiocy of modern
pop culture they will insist that this
kind of stuff really isn't that much
worse than the pop music that was being
churned out 20 or 30 years ago and you
know people were complaining about that
stuff back then and saying that it was
the death of Art and and you know they
were getting upset about it and and it
turned out fine yeah that's what people
say but the problem with that argument
is twofold number
one like it it obviously didn't turn out
for
fine the people who were making those
kinds of critiques of music and pop
culture 30 years ago have obviously been
absolutely
Vindicated they were worried that
American culture was headed over a cliff
they saw the signs everybody ignored
them when they talked about this and
they were proven correct on every point
the so-called Church ladies of the 80s
and 90s that were so upset about pop
culture back then they have been again
Vindicated perhaps more than any group
in history has ever been Vindicated in
fact if you were to go back in time to
1987 and find a church lady complaining
about pop culture at that time and you
were to play a clip of this ice spice
song performing you know the fart song
uh for the church lady she would say yes
see exactly that's exactly where I
thought this was leading I that
yes now and if that church lady had gone
out to the world and told them that in a
little over 30 years there would be
there would be semi literate women who
who can barely speak English rapping
about farts while they present their
asses to the camera like dogs at heat
everybody at the time would accuse them
of exaggerating like they would call her
crazy they would have said oh come on
it's not gonna get that bad don't be
ridiculous yet here we
are and second
lyrically uh this song like many other
songs produced today is is is yeah it's
it's only a few degrees dumber than The
Dumb Song SS of the past I'll give you
that it's true we long ago got to a
point where it's hard for the content to
get any Dumber once you arrive at a
juncture where hit recording artists are
making songs where they simply ramble
incoherently in a way that only vaguely
resembles any sort of human language
you've gotten about as dumb as you can
get you can't get more nonsensical than
nonsense but the overall product can
still get worse and it
is like music music 20 years ago was
dumb but at least it was exuberant you
know there was some life some feeling to
it it was dumb but it had character it
had feeling now there are many examples
from my childhood of dumb music with but
that had character and feeling that's
basically all of the 90s that's what the
if I had to summarize the 90s I'd say
like it was kind of dumb but it had
feeling it it it it was something uh
maybe one of the best examples is the
band Counting Crows uh they put out
several albums back in the '90s full of
songs were lyrically gibberish for the
most part but they captured somehow a
certain feeling a certain like Spirit uh
the classic counton Crow's hit is a song
called Mr Jones which I still love as a
90s as a you know as someone grew up in
the 90s and there's a there's a line in
that song that says so come dance this
silence down to the
morning now and in the '90s Again full
of songs that have lines like that I
don't know what that means like I think
it doesn't really mean anything but it's
kind of poetic and and again has feeling
it has
character a lot of music was like that
back then you didn't know what the
artist was trying to say exactly if he
was trying to say anything but you kind
of knew how you were supposed to feel
when you listen to it it had Soul if not
meaning but this stuff now I mean it has
none of the above you you you can see it
even in the performance that I just
played on top of the general crappiness
of the song it's also like lazy and
lacad isical and weirdly half-hearted
she's just sort of wandering around on
stage mumbling with no effort or
inflection take out the musical track
and ignore the substance of what she's
saying if you can call it substance and
it s based on the tone it sounds like
she's answering the phones that a
Verizon call center it sounds like she's
like giving someone directions on how to
get to write Aid or like it just it
sounds like this totally
perfunctory thing so it's it's Crash and
it's vulgar but it's also just blah
how are we even supposed to feel when we
listen to this stuff you know I made
this point with uh with with some other
dumb pop star recently and um Lil
nasx it's like what what feeling even is
there here what what did you feel the 45
writers that wrote that song you just
what the what feeling did they have when
they wrote it there's no feeling at all
even the sexuality of these songs is
empty and
Bland the songs are explicitly sexual to
a degree never seen before in popular
music and and the women spend the whole
time gyrating their butts to the camera
like some kind of mating ritual and yet
there's there's no sex appeal to any of
it it's it's offputting and boring and
so gross that the songs almost have a
stench to them there's nothing alive
here you could replace ice spice with AI
and you wouldn't lose any human ity
because there is no Humanity in it
there's a lot of flesh but but not flesh
and blood and that's the worst thing
about you know not that it's stupid and
vulgar and crass and profane although
all of that is bad and all that is true
but the worst thing is that it has no
heart and and no
brain it is zombie music for a zombie
culture in other words I don't like it
very
much and that is why ice spice is today
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there